Hi everybody!
I’m Adriene Hill.
Welcome to Crash Course Statistics!
And by everybody.
I don’t mean that literally.
There are give or take 7.6 Billion people
in the world.
When we hit a million views...that’s still
only point-zero-one (0.01%) percent of the
population.
So maybe Hi Almost Nobody!
Statistics are everywhere.
Some are explicitly part of our lives….like
...batting averages in baseball...expected
goals in soccer...or the percent chance the
meteorologist gives that it’ll snow...They’re
in the stone-faced warning from your doctor: “this procedure has a 2 percent chance of failure."
Statistics make a very good case for NOT buying
lottery tickets.
Other times statistics are less obvious--but
still with us.
Insurers use them to set their rates.
Researchers use them to try to figure out
if a drug can actually help regrow the hair
on the top of your head.
Or if there’s a correlation between dog
ownership and stress reduction.
Big retailers hire statisticians...to figure
out how to market to us better.
Apparently Target can pinpoint when a pregnant
woman might be due to give birth--based on
a change in what she buys.
Stores also use statistics to figure out how
to stock their shelves.
Turns out a whole lot of people rush to buy
strawberry pop-tarts before a hurricane hits.
So in advance of storms, Wal-Mart stocks up. For real.
And statistics is central to some of the cool technology we use everyday, like Siri and Alexa.
Mark Twain popularized the quote...“There
are three kinds of lies: lies, damned lies,
and statistics.”
And...yes statistics can be used to lie.
But they can also be used to help find the
truth.
The purpose of statistics is to to find the
Statistics allow us to uncover simplicity...inside
complexity.
To make sense of our world.
And part of what we’ll do in this series--is
figure out how to tell the difference between
statistics used for good.
Understanding.
Truth-telling.
And the statistics that we should question.
That are being used to mischaracterize the
world.
Understanding how statistics works, even if
you aren’t running regressions for fun….on
the weekends...can help you ask good questions
about other people’s studies and discoveries.
I’m Adriene Hill.
More than likely….I’ll be your host for
the series.
There is a one-in-74.8 million chance I will
be killed this year by an asteroid or other
near earth object collision.
When I’m not hanging out here.
Or researching the odds of death by freak
accident….I work in public radio.
I also co-hosted Crash Course Economics.
Where a statistically significant number of
you who commented didn’t like how...and
how much ...I moved my hands.
So I’ll work on it.
I’m excited for this series.
Some of these things I’ve thought about.
Some, I’ll be learning along with you.
It’s gonna be fun.
Cause at the end of the day statistics are
about us.
People.
And our world.
And how we relate to each other.
I’ll see you next week!